the Senate has approved a 19 billion
dollar disaster aid package it now goes
to the house the measure has more than
doubled in size since the house first
addressed this last year it would
allocate almost a billion and a half
dollars for Puerto Rico the most since
it was devastated by hurricanes Irma and
Maria in 2017 also money for us southern
states suffering from last fall's
hurricanes Midwestern states deluge with
springtime floods and fire ravaged rural
California it does not include four and
a half billion dollars requested by the
President to handle migrants at the
southern border he said this afternoon
he will get that immigration money later
severe weather has terrorized parts of
the Midwest and the plains this week and
it may not be over more today what was
described as a violent tornado ripped
through Missouri's Capitol City and
flooding remains a major problem in
Oklahoma correspondent matt finish in
Jefferson City Missouri tonight
this evening three people are dead in
Missouri and hundreds are returning to
damaged or obliterated houses and
businesses after powerful tornadoes
ripped through the region in one of the
hardest hit areas of Jefferson City one
young man says he and his mother curled
up together and prepared for the worst
what's the house started shaking and all
that I always say it was love you love
you love you because you can't say he
loved you enough until it's you know
you're gone a mother says she fought
tears to be strong in front of her
daughter and ran with her into the
bathroom amazing like nothing matters
like everything is I don't care about
any of this crap like I'm just happy
that were okay Missouri governor Mike
parson asking for the nation's prayers
for the at least three dead near Golden
City Missouri while saying he's grateful
there were no deaths from the
devastating tornado that ripped through
parts of the capitol city many states in
the southern plains and Midwest are not
in the clear the forecast calls for more
potential tornado outbreaks from Texas
to New York the Missouri River is
expected to crest at nine feet above
stage level north of Jefferson City and
the National Guard tells Fox News the
flooded Mississippi River will be closed
to commerce and recreation near st.
Louis and Brett happening right now not
every neighborhood like this one has
been cleared so search and rescue crews
are still going door-to-door looking for
survivors
Brett Matt Fenton live in Jefferson City
Matt thanks